et on commence ce débrief de cette
interview de yannick jadot et jacquet
pierre jacques beauregard bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous jean daniel
lévy de l'institut de sondage harris
interactive jean daniel donges merci
d'être avec nous et marion vigreux et
marion évidemment vous avez écouté cette
interview attentivement pendant une
heure on va revenir sur cet échange
parce que vous avez retenu alors un
échange qui a commencé autour de l'
attaque russe cette nuit de la centrale
nucléaire ukrainienne de zappos ridge à
la plus grande d'europe vladimir poutine
n'a plus de limite pour le candidat
europe ecologie les verts il faut
poursuivre les sanctions traquer les
oligarques livrer des armes à l'ukraine
et continuer le dialogue avec le chef du
kremlin mais yannick jadot préférait que
ce soit l'union européenne qui s'en
occupe et non emmanuel macron seul il
faut qu'il y ait au la seule charles
michel ursula von der leyen vladimir
poutine est un dictateur at il martelé
on n'est pas ami avec quelqu'un qui a
rasé grozny on n'est pas ami avec
quelqu'un qui empoisonne ses adversaires
et marion autres thématiques abordées
l'annoncé officielle de la candidature
d'emmanuel m'a coincé le même candidat
en pire commente yannick jadot pour lui
le président a une responsabilité dans
la montée des inégalités dans le pays
dans l'absence de politique
environnementale
ça a été un président de l'obuts
déclare-t-il il attend désormais un
débat avec le candidat car il ya
beaucoup de colère dans le pays il faut
l'apaiser il a aussi été question du
développement du nucléaire elle choix
des manuels macron de développer 6
nouveaux réacteurs repères c'est du
bricolage absolue dit yannick jadot qui
rappelle que l'uranium que nous
emportons gens notamment de piste sous
tutelle russe il redonne lui son
calendrier investissements sur les
économies d'énergie déploiement des
aides angers renouvelables fermeture au
fur et à mesure des réacteurs nucléaires
et sur le renouvelable il admet une part
de pollution et pour lui ça reste la
seule solution pour garantir notre
indépendance énergétique
autre sujet d'autres sujets de
préoccupation des français avait été
abordé et il propose la construction de
nouveaux logements sociaux
l'investissement dans les transports
collectifs la gratuité du covoiturage
mais aussi un chèque énergie de 400
euros pour compenser la hausse des prix
du carburant sur la santé le candidat
des verts est favorable à une obligation
d'installation des médecins dans les
déserts médicaux et pour le grand âge la
suppression des ehpad privé à but
lucratif
il veut également revoir toute la 4
carte des régions et proposer une
nouvelle politique de décentralisation
sur l'agriculture précarité des
agriculteurs installation des jeunes et
la souveraineté alimentaire il a répondu
la thur le bilan de la politique
agricole est une catastrophe dit yannick
jadot lui qui propose de reprendre la
dette des agriculteurs à condition
qu'ils passent au bio il propose
également de mobiliser une enveloppe de
13 milliards d'euros pour un pack de
transformation agricole il faut changer
de modèle dit il pour aller vers
l'agroécologie et s'affranchir des
importations de soja ou d'engrais azotés
et puis dernier point il a réagi à
l'exclusion de sandrine rousseau on a
appris ça hier soir oui la candidate
finaliste de la primaire écologiste ne
participera pas à la campagne du
candidat yannick jadot estime qu'elle
mène aux d'autre objectif que celle à
des présidentielles une attitude qui
n'est pas compatible avec la ligne de la
campagne elle ne parlera pas aux non
plus au nom des écologistes dans cette
campagne c'est une forme de
clarification at il dit il faut faire
valoir la discipline pour éviter les
prises de position personnelles et
parasites sa merci marion pour ce résumé
très complet de cette interview on va
revenir en détail bien sûr sur les
propositions est d'abord pierre jean
daniel une question plus large qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé dit yannick jadot
comment vous l'avez trouvée je les
trouvais fidèle à lui-même c'est-à-dire
il ya quelque chose
lors de la maîtrise je trouve de ces
sujets ils maîtrisent absolument
très bien je trouve les sujets
écologiques évidemment c'est les
premiers et qu'il le conte kg qui
concerne la famille des écologistes mais
presque un peu trop techno c'est à dire
qu' il ya quelque chose dans cette
campagne en tout cas il comprit
principalement chez yannick jadot qui
fait que alors qu'il devrait être
presque au sommet de cette élection il
c'est le moment où tout est français ont
compris qu'ils avaient un enjeu
absolument cruciale sur la question
écologiste yannick jadot devrait a
priori justement en tête a minima de la
gauche et des écologistes et peut-être
même de cette élection il patine dans
les sondages et je pense que c'est lié à
ça c'est lié au fait que ça ne prime pas
il est peut-être trop techno là encore
dans votre émission ce matin je les
trouvais il a pas pris de risque il
répond très bien à toutes les questions
c'est presque trop en bonne élève je
trouve et du coup ça ne rime pas je
pense que dans l'opinion publique
yannick jadot ne laisse pas
véritablement de traces même si on peut
lui reconnaître la maîtrise encore une
fois de sept dossiers mais je pense
qu'une élection présidentielle ne se
joue pas à ça et je trouve que affiches
et d'ailleurs où il avait très bien fait
l'ensemble des propositions qu'il a
tenus et qu'il a proposé pendant une
heure dans cette émission je ne vois pas
le projet le kit dessine pour la france
la vision qui le projette pour la france
dans les cinq prochaines années voire
plus immense propositions déjà une
proposition qui serait alors c'est pas
tant que des propositions qu une
perspective je trouve ça ne donne pas
matière à rêver vous savez c'est fabien
ou celle qui est cette campagne des
jours heureux il a imprimé parce que il
ya une part de rêve en politique quand
même l'abandon du rêve c'est un problème
d'être trop pragmatique d'être trop
technocratique ça fait pas rêver les
français je pense que les français dans
une période dans laquelle on vit même si
elle est dramatique
évidemment on besoin de se projeter mais
par une vision en positif et il
n'apporte pas ça je trouve yannick jadot
dans cette campagne et c'est bien
dommage parce que l'écologie doit être
portée justement de lumière plutôt
positive avec une vision de la société
optimiste et hélas je ne trouve pas cela
dans la campagne du giallo italien
mais c'est vrai que souvent mais elle
reproche aux écologistes d'être un peu
des doux rêveurs que il avait fait un
propos qui apparaissait comme étant
utopiste et irréaliste par la suite et
que quand on regarde de la manière dont
il ya les cadeaux mène sa campagne quand
on regarde de l'interview qu'elle a
donnée ce matin quand on écoute vos
commentaires effectivement fait
aujourd'hui c'est plus forcément une
critique qu'on effectue à l'égard des
écologistes il peut y avoir un débat
pour savoir si on est d'accord ou pas
d'accord on peut avoir une question
concernant la faisabilité avec des
enjeux internationaux mais en tout cas
ni sur la question du constat ni sur la
question la gravité de la situation que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui en matière de
dérèglement climatique en matière
d'effectifs n'a pas avoir pour les
individus en matière de conséquences que
cela peut avoir par exemple en matière
de santé aujourd'hui et il y a une forme
de contestation de ce que peuvent dire
les écologistes mais c'est vrai que là
la question du projet écologiste la
question en fait de ce que peut être
l'envi entre guillemets de vivre dans
une france qui serait dirigée par
yannick jadot aujourd'hui fait quelque
peu défaut ce qui est assez surprenant
c'est que ça n'a pas fonctionné en tout
cas que cette ce registre là et pas
fonctionné au cours des dernières
élections municipales alors certes y
avait une participation qui était faible
mais on a pu voir que d'un centre de
grandes villes notamment dans les
endroits en fait tout le système
politique apparaissait comme étant des
lycées sont en difficulté les
écologistes ont réussi à gagner ils ont
réussi à gagner alors même que leurs
candidats tous leurs candidats n'étaient
pas connus ce qui apparaissait comme
étant une nouveauté et autour d'une idée
on arrivait globalement à se dire
j'arrive à voir ce que peut être ma
ville est dirigée par un écologiste au
convoyer ce que ça pouvait être en
matière de politiques publiques c'est à
dire quel type de transport va être
développé quel type d'alimentation va
être portée tel type de rapport on peut
avoir d'une manière générale avec la vie
au quotidien et là c'est vrai que cette
difficulté existe là aujourd'hui elle
préexistait à la situation qu'on a pu
voir en matière de tension au niveau
international mais il y avait toujours
cette petite interrogation de se dire
est ce qu'on arrive à voir ce que peut
être une france en gros en 2027 qui
aurait été dirigée par un écologiste et
qui nous permettrait de voir globalement
les modifications le type de vie au
quotidien que l'on explique pour vous
jean daniel le score de yannick jadot
pour le moment dans les sondages c'est à
dire qu'il est aux alentours de 5% alors
que l'écologie ça fait partie des
préoccupations des français est ce que
pour vous c'est ça qui explique ce
faible score pour ça y participent on
peut dire que d'une manière générale la
gauche a baissé depuis septembre dernier
alors qu'ils ont été demandés notamment
au regard de ce qui s'était passé en
allemagne allemagne c'était ça m'a
complètement inversé donc au fur et à
mesure en fait que la kompa s'est
déroulé les écologistes et la gauche
traditionnelle ont réussi à progresser
là ça n'a pas été le cas parce que la
thématique écologique et le mental n'a
pas été au centre du débat alors même
qu'il s'agit d'une des principales
préoccupations de la part de nos
compatriotes et également parce qu'à pas
toujours eu la perception qui est une
forme d'articulation entre les questions
écologiques et environnementales d'un
côté et les conséquences économiques et
sociales de l'autre les français sont
prêts à entendre qu'il y ait une
transformation la cité qui est une
transformation même d'une partie de
l'autre modèle économique et d'être
modèle social mais que ceci n'a pas été
entendu c'est vrai en fait que quand
vous regardez il n'y a pas eu non plus
cette perception qui une forme de
dynamique ni à la télévision ni même
dans les meetings et que malgré tout ça
joue très fortement dans les dynamiques
d'opinion de voir ce qui se passe
également à la télévision est-ce que la
situation actuelle situation
internationale ne joue pas contre
yannick jadot ou est-ce qu'il va pas
être contraint de revoir un peu son
logiciel
l'accompagné inédite elle est évidemment
complexe pour tous les candidats d'abord
parce qu'ils me donnent macron était
lui-même pas candidat jusqu'à hier soir
aussi évidemment parce que le contexte
géopolitique évidemment la guerre
russo ukrainienne
prend de la place dans l'espace
médiatique et que chacun des candidats
doit réviser son agenda politique de
campagne pour coller à l'actualité se
doter d avoir une inquiétude des
français sur notre indépendance notre
indépendance énergétique justement
hélas à l'aune de cette guerre tragique
je pense que ça devrait savourer et nous
y avons une responsabilité nous aussi en
tant que journaliste remettre le sens de
ce qu'est une président une élection
présidentielle je le disais tout à
l'heure sur le déroulé presque des
propositions des ninjas d'auge je pense
que les français est en moins se
dérouler des propositions qu une vision
des choses une vision de ce que doit
être la france et je pense que à l'aune
de justement de ce changement de mondial
de des relations même mondiale et du
climat géopolitique un président de la
république ou en tout cas un prétendant
ou une prétendante à l'élection
présidentielle devraient de me dire
c'est quoi la france de demain quel est
le rôle de la france dans le dans les
conflits du monde et je pense que si
cette ce qui nous arrive aujourd'hui ce
qui arrive au monde avec cette guerre
russo ukrainienne devrait permettre
justement à chacun des candidats de
redire quel est l'objectif de sa
candidature c'est quoi la france c'est
quoi l'idée de puissance est ce que
vraiment les idées de puissance a encore
du sens aujourd'hui puissance quoi comme
le dit manu macron puissance économique
puissance énergétique puissance de paix
comme il le dit pour ne pas dire
évidemment puissance militaire c'est
quoi le projet d'un président de la
république c'est quoi le projet de la
france qu'elle france demain dans le
monde et qu'elle qu'elle le diplomatie
après un candidat l'élection
présentielle et je pense que c'est ça
qui doit être aujourd'hui au coeur de
l'actualité de cette campagne
présidentielle est sans doute yannick
jadot doit-il y répondre je pense que
chacun des candidats devra y répondre
encore faut-il qu'il puisse y avoir un
débat emmanuel macron visiblement n'en a
pas envie j'ai entendu une quête de dire
souhaité qu'ils participent à ces débats
ce serait intéressant justement de voir
s'affronter
sept différentes se fait par exemple sur
la question du nucléaire on va parler de
cette question évidemment yannick jadot
on a longuement parlé quand on voit la
dépendance de l'allemagne vis-à-vis du
gaz russe qui a canada elle est un peu
pieds et poings liés finalement
l'allemagne au début de cette guerre en
ukraine est ce que les français ne
seront ne serait pas tenté de se dire
mais il faut qu'on a sur notre
indépendance énergétique et du coup
adhéré au discours des manuels mâcon qui
dit notre indépendance énergétique c'est
le nucléaire et est ce que du coup ça va
pas pénaliser yannick jadot
on va voir et justement c'est ça qui
serait intéressant c'est de voir une
confrontation d'idées une confrontation
de points de vue entre le président
sortant yannick jadot et les autres
candidats la question de l'indépendance
et emmanuel macron la la pause et dans
son allocution à la télévision en disant
qu'on avait changé d'ère on avait changé
de monde que la crise climatique avec
aujourd'hui la crise russo ukrainienne
doit nous conduire à nous poser une
question qu'est la question de
l'indépendance mais attention à ne pas
tout faire d'eux de leur dépendance
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde
interdépendant faut arrêter de penser
que la france seule peut quelque chose
on n'est pas on est on est dépendant
évidemment de de relation et donc je
pense que là notamment la résolution des
conflits ne peut pas se faire aimer et
je trouve que je suis là c'est bien
répondu yannick jadot que ça peut pas
être que en bilatéral en tutoyant le
président russe c'est une stratégie
globale mondiale qui doit s'imposer
aujourd'hui on va revenir sur cette
question de l'ukraine mais sur le
nucléaire jean daniel on va écouter dans
quelques secondes yannick jadot mais
est-ce que du coup les français peuvent
changer d'avis a déjà un revirement de
l'opinion ça veut dire une évolution
avignon mais c'est pas un sujet si
structurants que ça et contrairement à
ce qu'on croit en fait même dans les
enquêtes que l'on menait auprès des
électeurs écologistes ou des
sympathisants écologistes la question
nucléaire n'était pas la question
centrale et on voyait bien en fait qu'on
avait d'une manière générale de la cité
française des français qui étaient
partagés à l'égard du nucléaire et que
globalement même chez les écologistes il
s'agit c'est loin s'en faut de leur
première motivation de vote leur
première motivation de vote thoune
autour d'une d'une interrogation
concernant le dérèglement climatique les
effets que cela peut avoir et les
conséquences en matière de santé donc on
n'était pas forcément sur une thématique
qui apparaissait comme étant absolument
centrale et ce qui est d'ailleurs
intéressant c'est qu'alors même
qu'aujourd'hui en fait on est face à des
français qu'ils sont profondément
inquiet concernant le dernier climatique
on est profondément inquiète à l'égard
des effets en matière de santé de ce que
peut être la qualité de l'air la qualité
de l'eau l'alimentation que ces sujets
là en fait ne sont pas vraiment au
centre du débat alors qu'il s'agit du
ressort de mobilisation en faveur des
écologistes etc la question nucléaire ou
la question d'indépendance énergétique
ne constitue pas en tout cas auprès du
coeur de cet électorat là qui est
sensible à l'écologie ou qui pourraient
être amenés à voter en faveur de yannick
jadot je dis pas un sujet secondaire
avant tout cas qui n'est pas le sujet
qui va structurer profondément leurs
comportements électoraux on va l'écouter
yannick jadot sur cette question du
nucléaire et notamment sur la question
des repères vous avez un président de la
république qui dit vous avez des
problèmes de factures d'énergie
aujourd'hui on a un problème de climat
aujourd'hui je vous propose de
multiplier par 6 8 14 un fiasco
aujourd'hui pour avoir des ep en 2040
2045 tout ça c'est du bricolage absolue
oui sur cette question pierre jacqmin
sur la réponse chez de ce fiasco
d'albert alors fini dit qu'il va quand
même avoir un auditeur sur le père de
flamanville il dit pas je vais l'arrêté
je vais le poursuivre mais dit il y aura
un audit tu t en fonction de l'audit et
de la vie de les parlementaires je
déciderai mais vous le sou levier il ya
forcément un paradoxe c'est à dire
qu'effectivement les écologistes avaient
réussi à imposer l'idée qu'il fallait
sortir progressivement du nucléaire et
la société s'était préparé à ça et cette
campagne effectivement un peu changé la
donne c'est à dire que l'ensemble des
candidats y compris d'ailleurs ceux à
gauche qui plaidait pour une sortie du
nucléaire assez rapide tout le monde on
peut changer de braquet et donc
aujourd'hui effectivement tout le monde
a plus ou moins compris que sur des
provocations dépendance énergétique un
début d'indépendance énergétique le
nucléaire on allait en avoir besoin y
compris c'était peut-être une énergie
la plus fiable pour pour l'avenir donc
il ya cette difficulté vous le disais de
yannick jadot d'être quasiment le seul
candidat a plaidé pour la peine c'est la
wii et une partie de rêve où l'utopie de
la part des écologistes encore que je
pense que le discours est totalement
construit totalement v ou pas
verrouillée mais il est il et il est
comment dire je le trouve crédible et le
lait de discours des écologistes qui
consiste à dire aujourd'hui il faut
viser la sortie du nucléaire en misant
sur les énergies renouvables quelle
qu'elle soit caricatures beaucoup sur le
sur les sur l'éolien mais il n'ya pas
que ça il ya l'hydraulique il ya
évidemment bien d'autres d'autre
alternative que les écologistes
proposent donc là dessus ils sont plutôt
je trouve crédible il ya une forme de
crédibilité est bon c'est vrai que la
difficulté c'est qu'il vit face à des
candidats qui propose aux totalement
l'inversé j'ai le sentiment que la
société bascule justement dans cette
idée que pour des questions
d'indépendance de dépendance plutôt
d'ailleurs il va falloir maintenir et
investir dans le nucléaire c'est
compliqué parce que ça nécessite aussi
un discours sur la formation voyez
aujourd'hui si vous dites aux jeunes le
nucléaire demain c'est fini personne va
s'intégrer ça doit s'insérer dans les
filières nucléaires d'apprentissage
d'études et de recherches sur la
question du nucléaire donc il faut aussi
jongler sur un discours qui soit un
discours on va créer de l'emploi avec le
nucléaire on va créer de l'emploi sur
les énergies renouvelables donc c'est
là-dessus où il est ni jadot justement
il a du mal à je trouve peut-être à
rebondir ou en tout cas à nuancer son
propos on va parler de la guerre en
ukraine un début de lyn thériault
évidemment la guerre en ukraine qui fait
l'actualité qui inquiète les français
yannick jadot l'a dit
on soutient le chef de l'état mais il
dit qu'il ne devrait pas y aller seul
que c'est à l'union européenne de parler
avec vladimir poutine est ce que ce
sujet est en train d'écraser la campagne
est de faire qu'il n'y aura pas de
campagne jean daniel pour est-ce que
déjà le sujet de l'ukraine écrase
accompagne la réponse est oui ce qu'on
est face à des français qu'ils sont
terriblement préoccupé la réponse est
oui et dans un même élan avec à l'heure
actuelle un niveau de confiance qui est
exprimée à l'égard d' emmanuel macron
qui est largement supérieur à l'égard
des autres candidats et ce qui est même
intéressant c'est que c'est le seul en
fait aujourd'hui de disposer d'un niveau
de confiance absolue et que tous les
autres candidats l'élection présentielle
ne suscite pas en fait un niveau de
confiance assez nette avec une personne
et qui plus que les autres en fait
aujourd'hui patty à l'heure actuelle de
7,2 cette difficulté est qu'il s'agit de
valérie pécresse dont on voit bien en
fait que son électorat considère que en
l'espèce emmanuel macron entrée qui mêle
à la hauteur des événements ça n'est pas
une situation qui est nouvelle et en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que ça
vient quand même relativement le droit
et que déjà même avant l'invasion de lui
traîne par par la russie il y avait une
confiance concernant les enjeux
internationaux qui était très clair en
faveur d' emmanuel macron aussi parce
qu'il est en poste aussi parce que il
des chefs des armées aussi parce qu'il
est reprenant la france au niveau
international bien plus en fait que les
autres candidats à l'élection
présentielle donc ça ça vient ajouter un
élément supplémentaire dans des traits
d'image qui préexistait à l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie elle est en
train de bloquer la campagne dans sa
lettre emmanuel macron sa lettre publiée
ce matin dans 'la dans la presse
régionale il dit je ne pourrais pas mené
campagne comme je l'aurais souhaité en
raison du contexte il y aura pas de
campagne
vraisemblablement il n'a pas fait le
choix de ressorts de rentrer dans dans
l'arène politique et donc de se
confronter aux autres candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
c'est encore une fois on est on vit
quand même assez tragique et inédit on
sort d'une crise sanitaire
on rentre dans un conflit qui risque de
durer comme lui-même le président de la
république l'a annoncé il fallait
s'attendre à ce que ce conflit dure
je crains qu effectivement il n'y a pas
de débat qu'il n'y a pas de véritable
campagne présidentielle emmanuel macron
fait presque comme si tout ça n'allait
être qu'une formalité il va être
président jusqu'au bout il a dit jusqu'à
la dernière ce jusqu'aux dernières
secondes jusqu'aux dernières minutes et
qu' il n'y aura pas eu de campagne
véritable n'aurait pas eu de débat
télévisé il y aura peut-être pas de
meeting de la part du candidat macron il
a annulé pour les raisons que l'on
connaît qui sont celles de la guerre
russo ukrainienne son premier meeting
devait avoir lieu à marseille non hélas
je pense qu'il va y avoir une grande
frustration de la part des autres
candidats qui avaient envie justement de
solliciter emmanuel macron pour avoir
son bilan pour connaître son bilan pour
qu'ils fassent aussi le point sur son
action de ces cinq années donc ça va
être une campagne
étonnante inédite hélas ou peut-être que
la démocratie va en pâtir oui
frustration des autres candidats disent
bien est-ce qu'il peut aussi avoir une
frustration chez les français jean
daniel way ce que les français
comprennent que dans le contexte actuel
et bien c'est normal qu'il n'y a pas de
compagne présidente les deux
indéniablement quand on est posée il ya
quelques semaines en fait la question de
savoir est ce qu emmanuel macron doit se
déclarer ou est-ce qu au regard en fait
des grands enjeux internationaux et
sanitaires il est autre guillemets
légitime que le président la réplique
retard de sa déclaration de candidature
on avait des français qui étaient
partagés mais les personnes qui
déclaraient qu'ils avaient l'intention
de voter pour emmanuel macron au suc
était un peu plus à gauche ou un peu
plus à droite sur l'échiquier politique
considérais que c'était légitime que le
prix d'un clic notre pas tout de suite
en campagne y avait une pression
médiatique et hissaient il ya une
pression militante mais qui n'était pas
forcément la pression de la part de
l'opinion et dans un même élan les
français considèrent que tous les cinq
ans au moins on s'arrête on se pose et
on arrive à se dire qui sommes nous où
allons nous et turquie pour vous conter
pour pouvoir avoir un destin commun qui
globalement nous emmène de manière
positive ils en sont privés on peut
danser mesure considérer que déjà en
2007 il ya eu une entente débat en tout
cas c'est ce que nous avait indiqué des
français que le mandat qui était fixé
mène le maquereau et des pas extrêmement
clair ça c'est des traduit au cours des
élections législatives a été peu
souligné mais moins 50% de participation
au premier tour des élections de sétif
-43% une participation au deuxième tour
des élections hâtives ça a été des
records d'abstention
depuis la création de la vème république
dans le cadre de ce conte ce titre dans
le cadre de cette consultation
électorale je dis pas que ça s'est
traduit de manière manifeste par le
mouvement des gilet jaune mais en tout
cas une des sources des gilet jaune a
été aussi cette difficulté initiale pas
de mandat clair fixé au présent applique
et pas de corps intermédiaires ou de
capacité à pouvoir se projeter à travers
une expression de ce que peut être la
confiture et et politiques de manière
intellectuelle marques et qui se traduit
à travers d'autres types de
comportements et d'autres types de
manifestations un moment sur la campagne
des verts pour terminer on va écouter
yannick jadot puis évidemment on l'a
fait réagir à l'exclusion fière de son
équipe de campagne de sandrine rousseau
et bien vu que sandrine rousseau depuis
des semaines depuis la primaire
[Musique]
mène d'autres campagnes que la campagne
présidentielle tout ça n'est pas
compatible avec la loyauté
la ligne politique
de la campagne et donc on lentilles en
moi je prends acte
d'une énième de d'énièmes prise de
position qui ne sont pas seuls de la
campagne
clarification finalement a dit yannick
jadot clarification je trouve que les
écologistes on l'a pas du tout à l'heure
quand on parlait de cette candidature de
migado mais les écologistes ont réussi
d'une primaire qui a été plutôt bien
organisé au moment où on parler
d'identité
d'immigration en permanence et eux ils
avaient réussi à faire resurgir dans le
débat public dans le débat politique la
question écologique et justement les
intérêts et les points d'intérêt que
sont ceux de la gauche et les
écologistes qu'ils avaient réussi ça il
y avait deux lignes qui effectivement
s'affrontaient qui était celle de
sandrine rousseau et jean yves jadot
mais quasiment à égalité puisqu'ils sont
arrivés à 25 % 25 % chacun donc les deux
ont une forme de légitimité c'est vrai
que c'est grosso a assez mal digéré
d'avoir perdu à quelques voix près et
yannick jadot ne lui a pas fait non plus
la place sans doute qu'elle espère qu
elle estimé pouvoir obtenir l a été
quand même finalement nommée présidente
du conseil politique des écologistes
elle n'était pas porte parole la porte
parole était aussi candidate à
l'élection présidentielle
delphine batho et c'est vrai qu'on voit
plus aujourd'hui sandrine rousseau que
delphine batho donc c'était compliqué
effectivement entre les deux d'autant
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément les mêmes
lignes je trouve que l'attitude de
yannick jadot en tout cas la réponse
qu'il a porté ce matin n'est pas tout à
fait à la hauteur c'est à dire qu'il
considérait que peut-être possiblement à
l'orée des stratégies de reprendre le
parti état d'abord c'est pas très grave
et puis surtout ça n'empêche pas de
faire une campagne écologique en
parallèle même avec des sensibilités
différentes et en 30 secondes de la fin
ben ça on reçoit occupe une place qui
était extrêmement importante qui est
bien plus importante par exemple que
celle que peut occuper eric ciotti dans
le cadre de la campagne aujourd'hui par
exemple 2 valérie pécresse et dans ce
contexte là on voyait bien qu'ils
avaient quand même des divergences
n'étaient pas que des divergences
tactiques qu'ils étaient des divergences
de fond et qui n'étaient pas entièrement
réglée et que sur les plateaux à chaque
fois qu'on écoutait sandrine rousseau on
n'est pas forcément entendu le sentiment
d'entendre quelqu'un qui parlait au nom
de yannick jadot mais qu il entendait
vraiment une parole qui apparaissait
comme étant singulière
[Musique]